is from the new york post
it says a pregnant texas woman who was
given a traffic ticket for driving solo
in an hov lane intends to fight the
citation arguing that her fetus should
be considered a separate person given
the lone star state's views and abortion
motherb brandy baton 34 told the dallas
morning news that she was given the
ticket on june 29th after being pulled
over by police while driving on a
highway near the city
she told the newspaper quote i was
driving to pick up my son i knew i
couldn't be a minute late so i took the
hov lane as i exit hov lane there was a
checkpoint at the end of the exit i
slammed on my brakes and i was pulled
over by police
the cop asked if she had a passenger
with her and she responded that in fact
she did i pointed to my stomach and said
my baby girl is right here this she is a
person
um he said oh no it's going to be two
people outside of the body that's what
it has to be so now she's fighting in a
court saying that well
it's pretty clear from the context here
that she's she's pro-abortion and so
this was her way this was a kind of
gotcha moment here
um against the the pro-lifers saying hey
you see what happens
you see you get rid of abortion and now
all of a sudden there's confusion in the
hov lane
and i guess she expects that we as
pro-lifers will say well never mind that
well i thought that it would be good to
stop killing babies but if we don't if
you're telling me that uh that getting
rid of abortion means that there's
slight confusion hov lane well never
mind let's just kill the babies again
that's a price that we simply can't pay
now there is an easy way around this if
you want to preserve the integrity of
the hov lane and also
um not kill babies like if you want to
do both of those things the way around
it is to say that uh you have to have
passengers in a passenger seat that's
what we mean by hov so
that's the way around it very just a
really simple clarification i think we
get us around this or
here's what i would prefer
just get rid of the stupid hov lane to
begin with
okay so
which which is which is not a bad thing
as far as i'm concerned
so this is another example of democrats
proposing something
very attractive
as a way to punish us for banning
abortion
and in this case the the implication is
that we'd have to abolish the carpool
lane
if we don't have abortion anymore
which great let's do that because the
left lane is supposed to be for people
driving fast who cares how many people
are in the in the car with you
if you want to be in the left most lane
then you should just be driving fast you
should be driving a lot faster than the
cars in the other lane that's the only
qualification that there should be on
the left lane and that should be rigidly
enforced as far as i'm concerned
i mean people who go
like five miles under the limit in the
in the speed in the fast lane
like forget about finding we should be
pulling them over and putting them in
jail for for 30 days to let them think
about it
um and that's fine with me so let's just
do that
uh but this is this is what this is what
the democrats have been doing is in
proposing things
that
like claiming that there are
implications to get rid of getting rid
of abortion and those implications are
actually great here's another one
this is a jack
uh
cochiarella i guess he's a democrat
strategist he tweeted this yesterday or
a couple days ago he said if republicans
really believe life begins at conception
shouldn't someone who is pregnant be
allowed to claim their baby as a
dependent on their taxes
sounds great let's do that too it's
fantastic get rid of the hov lane only
have a fast lane you drive you drive
fast in the left lane fantastic um claim
and depend you know you can claim
your unborn child as it depends on your
taxes that means a tax break
so that's great too
what does he imagine this is a democrat
strategist who has no idea he's supposed
to be a strategist for the democrats
which should mean that he's an expert on
republicans and conservatives his
opponents he should know us
like the back of his own hand he has no
understanding of us whatsoever
he thinks that he can threaten us with a
tax break
this is just like the ones that you know
the people that are saying well if we
don't have abortion then that means that
we're we're gonna have to have
abstinence
before marriage
right it's the end of hookup culture
great awesome well if we don't have
abortion well that means that we have to
require men
all right
if i turn that off
well if we don't have abortion that
means we have to require men to care for
their babies
like from conception
you wouldn't want that would you no i do
want that all this is great abstinence
before marriage get rid of the carpool
lane tax breaks men taking care of their
kids
the these are according to the opponents
of um
of pro-lifers according to the pro
boards themselves these are the
consequences of getting rid of abortion
so it's just it's a win upon win upon
win
i see nothing but upside and when i
think that we've seen all the upside we
could possibly see they give us some
more upside
and the great thing is that i didn't
need any upside other than
we're not killing babies anymore that
would've been good enough for me i
didn't need any of this other this extra
stuff but this is just you know whipped
cream cherries sprinkles on top this is
everything we got the whole ice cream
sundae now
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you could
also catch my show on spotify apple
podcast or wherever you get your podcast
so go check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated